i missed old white people
like asia like
like gran torino yeah like i like i like
you know i grew up i grew up with such a
hostile like
racism what about uh even
what about that story i saw in tmz about
tony hinchcliffe didn't he speak up
about it like at the time
so uh so what when you mean the opener
yeah when he called the eyeopener yeah
there's something like in and out to be
fair i'm gonna i'm gonna be completely
honest with you okay
and asia's gonna be so mad at me for
this
but
like one time this gay comic brought me
up on stage
he's a friend of mine right
so i called it i i go one more time for
the agate
right
and he goes [ __ ] you you you know me you
flat-faced was he pissed or was he no
we're doing
comedy you know i mean
you [ __ ] fat or whatever and then i'm
like
[ __ ] you you know and we're like we're
killing right like the audience is by
eating it up it's like a rapport that we
have right it's like
you know um we have the relationship
this kid is his opener right
and it's like the things that i've said
about my openers have been crazy
you know i mean like insane right but
it's like they were it was never taped
right and i think that um
it's tony's audience right
he
asked this kid to over open for him
right there's a rapport that there's
sort of like this unsaid rule that like
you know
in in that environment it's safe
to [ __ ] make fun of each other this
and that and i understood kind of what
tony was doing you know i mean it's like
you know
would he do it to me
no
because if he did i would do it back to
him right
like i i i could have said 10 things
that would have made him cry because i
just know personal things about him you
know what i mean but it's like you know
to me when i saw that at first i was
like oh that's kind of [ __ ] up right
but then when i actually thought about
it i was just like
it's it's it
yeah i mean it's it's kind of
tony hinchcliffe is a is a master
comic he's a great man he's a good
writer really really good yeah and he's
got that kind of
sort of like dry like you know
like almost like jezelnik almost kind of
like we're like offensive yeah dry
offensive and so it wasn't like too far
out of his
style of comedy you know it was a little
bit on the nose like not not not as uh
it's provocative it's edgy people
laughed nervously you know i mean but
it's like
it's also kind of like i could see in
the moment like i'm punk rock
you don't mean i'm edgy you know i mean
this is
against
the culture right now you know and it's
like you know i understand all that but
you know is tony hinchcliffe in his
heart
a racist no
you know me was he just
doing his brand of comedy yeah yeah and
i think that um i agree
i do i mean i really do and being like
there was that other kid i forgot his
name shane gillis
yeah on the saturday night live yeah
right he got fired from saturday
no he got hired and then he didn't even
do a show yet and then having him on
tiger bell in a couple weeks
and um
it's just another thing it's like he
said it on a podcast
right and as a comedian i think anything
goes
for me
you know i mean it's like
you know you say crazy things i've i've
said so many crazy things right and it's
like some of them aren't cool you know
me with today's culture and today's you
know
how this it shifted you know it shifted
on us the world you know and it's like
um
i know i was just like you know
also as an asian guy at first when i saw
it i was a little offended like tony's
you're my first initial reaction but i
have to think about
i mean
who he is
what the environment is you know i mean
and um
what his heart says you know did you
shoot him a text
no at the in the beginning no because i
don't know him
you mean shane gillis no
tony tony no
i never texted him
because um
i thought i didn't think it was that big
of a deal until later i don't know
he has
moved on he survived it it wasn't like
anything
like uh
what about ari shafir like what's going
on with him lately what do you mean i
remember when he like did his his kobe
joke
that was not good for him
and and i wonder
that's another example of what i'm going
to say is that he's on brand
yeah and um i thought i personally
thought it was poor timing
you know i mean
i personally thought that it was um
just
unsavory it's not not cool right you
mean
you got to leave some time
he didn't do that he did it immediately
yeah you know i mean and so it was just
all off-putting and it wasn't yeah it
was that was a tough one that was a
tough one but still at the end of the
day it's like he's doing what he does
that's his style right and it's like if
you don't like it don't follow him yeah
right i found out kobe died from ari's
post
[Laughter]
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on amazon and
type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude